the gods live every day
from the earliest memories of the cirrus
near creation and forever on
under the looming shadow of past
disaster and future torment
this is all largely due to loki the
complicated ambivalent figure who lives
alongside the gods but compulsively
troubles them
snori in his prose edda characterizes
loki in largely negative terms though
with a slight qualification at the end
one is counted among the asir gods who
is called by some the slanderer of the
gods or the first maker of lies or the
blemish on all the gods and all
humankind
he is handsome in appearance evil in
disposition and extremely changeable in
mood
before all others he is the champion of
the kind of wisdom that is deceit
and he uses lies for all his purposes
he often causes the god's terrible
problems and just as often solves those
problems with his schemes
loki's own origin is clouded in
uncertainty his father is said to be an
anti-god his father's name means
dangerous striker which old norse is for
loki's mother is said to be a goddess
with a name that means leaf island leo
these names meanings are unusually
transparent
it's possible that their poetic
circumlocutions invented to cover up
their regular names
but if so the cover names were so
effective that the regular names were
forgotten
other details of loki's origin are
entirely lost to the forgotten lore of
the past
loki is not an adopted son of odin in
spite of the marvel universe portrayal
in fact one of odinn's strange names in
poetry is loki's friend
this name might be accusatory in nature
given the destruction loki will one day
reap
but it also reminds us of the mysterious
pledge that odinn and loki made to one
another that they would never drink
separately as recorded in the poem
lokasena in the poetic edda
of loki before adulthood snorre writes
in the prose etta only that he had two
brothers and says nothing about either
of them
neither of loki's brothers is mentioned
in the slightest detail in any of the
poems of the poetic edda either
there was also something pretty strange
about loki's shadowy birth
many of the asser gods including the
most prominent odin thor
have anti-god mothers
but the fact that loki's father is from
the wrong side of the cosmos is almost
unique shared only with tyr
but thierry and loki aren't otherwise
similar figures
tutor's willingness to sacrifice a hand
to imprison the wolf in their ear gives
him a disciplined honorable character
that's the opposite of loki's chaotic
and destructive nature
remember gods have higher status than
anti-gods and is considered socially
appropriate for women to marry men of
higher or equal status
but this is the reverse status of loki's
and tears parents and that implies
something not quite right in the union
of these two god's parents perhaps an
abduction
or some other unusual tale that
unfortunately is lost to us
but whatever the details of where loki
came from
what has been preserved is that he
himself has dallied with many beings of
the anti-god family both female and male
beings
as well as associated monsters and even
animals
and these dalliances would cause the
gods suffering for the most part
the worst of loki's affairs was with an
anti-goddess who had the ominous name of
sorrow offerer or angrboda
each of loki and angkor botha's children
is foretold to bring harm to the gods
the huge wolf fenrir the goddess hell
and the world-sized serpent that
encircles mankind's dwellings in the
outer ocean and is known as jormungandr
or often simply as the midgard serpent
the gods learned that these children
were growing up in jotunheimer the homes
of the anti-gods and sent messengers
to retrieve the children and bring them
into the god's enclosure oscar or asgard
snori tells us the gods sent for these
children in response to exactly the
prophecies that foretold these children
would do the god's irreparable harm such
as the prophecy in the poem bola spa
presumably the gods wish to have control
over the fates of beings they were
doomed to come into conflict with
when these three ill prophecy children
were brought before odinn he first threw
the huge serpent into the outer ocean
the serpent lies in weight out there and
the waves that surround our human realm
viethgarder midgard
thus it is usually called the midgard
serpent
an older poetry it may be called by the
apparent name jorman gander but this
means simply huge monster and is
probably more of an older descriptive
term for it than a true name
odinn then threw loki's daughter hell
into nivelham the watery realm from the
creation story
nivelham will become her domain as queen
of the dead and it will be renamed hell
when it becomes her domain that's
according to the story anyway
in fact the name hell in old norse and
english alike must originally mean the
buried after world itself the word is
from the same root as english whole
we'll return to take a closer look at
hell and her domain late in the course
and our lesson on the afterlife
but the biggest problem for the gods
contrary to what you might expect was
with the wolfe son of loki the enormous
fenrir
according to a prophecy well known to
the gods this wolf would be the death of
odinn at the final battle of ragnarok
and yet the beginning of the wolf story
is strangely peaceful even
domestic
the gods fed the wolf at home sister
sounding like he's talking about a pet
dog
snori does note that only the god
theodore had the courage to come close
enough to give the wolf food
the gods did however note with
apprehension that the wolf
grew larger every single day
the assyr gods did fear the prophecies
that foretold the danger the wolf would
cause
but they have brought the wolf within
the enclosure of their realm asgard and
they were unable to harm a living being
once he or she had come inside there
so the asean decided to try to restrain
the wolf instead
they built a strong chain and put it on
the wolf
but the wolf was stronger than their
chain and he broke out of the chain with
ease
the gods then forged another chain that
was stronger and brought it to fenrir
they told him that if he could break out
of a chain as strong as this one he
would become truly famous indeed
the wolf looked at the chain and could
tell it was very strong
but he knew he'd never become famous
without taking a few risks and he
allowed the asthea to tie it around him
then he broke free out of this one as
well
by the way if you read old norse
literature it's very seldom that you get
any internal monologue from a character
the wolf's thoughts here as related by
snorri he knew he'd never become famous
without taking a few risks
are some of the only ones ever related
of any character in a norse myth or saga
so
failing to keep the wolf chained up on
their own
the god sent freud's messenger skire
near to the so-called dark elves to get
them to make a chain strong enough to
hold fenrir
scare near then went to some dwarves
there is reason to think that elves and
dwarves are overlapping categories of
not synonyms and this scene is one
reason
well these dwarves were ordered to make
a chain that could not be broken by a
wolf that could break anything a sort of
immovable object made an irresistible
force
but the dwarves had engineering skills
equal to any challenge
they made their chain out of six things
that don't exist
the sound of a cat walking a woman's
beard a fish's breath a mountain's roots
a bird spit and a bear's sinews
now the last of the six impossible
ingredients apparently refers the way
that bears look like a smooth carpet
walking without apparent muscles or
tendons and tension under their fur
this impossible chain when complete was
as soft and thin as a thread of silk
with the marvelous chain in hand the
asean gods rode out to the island on a
small lake within their realm where they
were keeping fenrir
they showed the wolf the chain or silk
thread as it magically appeared to be
and asked him to try breaking this one
the god said this silk thread would
probably be no challenge for fenrir
given how soft and thin it was and what
much stronger chains he had already
broken on account of how strong he was
nevertheless the wolf was suspicious
maybe he could see a little vicious
breath
though it seems little said the wolf if
this is done with cunning and treachery
that band won't come on my feet
but the god said surely the wolf would
be able to break this little silk band
when he had broken iron chains before
and they added if you can't break the
silk band that proves you are not
someone for us to be afraid of and will
release you
the wolf said then let one of you put
his hand in my mouth as a pledge that
this is not done with a false heart
now the gods all looked sideways at one
another and none of them wanted to put
his hand in the wolf's mouth
but at length theodore stepped forward
and put his right hand on the wolf's
jaws
the gods then put the silk band on the
wolf and it got harder when fenrir
struggled against it and harder still
the longer he struggled to break it the
wolf was truly trapped
then all the ass he had laughed except
tyr who lost his hand
fenrir was now taken to a deep cave and
his chain
fastened even deeper yet in the earth
below
the wolf still tried to bite the gods
through the whole process but they
shoved a sword into his jaws to prop his
mouth open
the saliva that flows from his open
mouth as he sits madly eagerly
anticipating his freedom in ragnarok
is called
hope
it tells us something about the
characteristic norse pessimism that in
all the stories the ed is it is here
in the slabbering madness of the wolf
killer of odinn that we find the word
hope
readers of the story in snorri's prose
edda which i have translated nearly
verbatim here are often struck by how
calm or well chill the wolf is
there is no indication from fenrir's
actions or words that he actually means
harmed odin or any of the other gods
the wolf is apprehensive of the gods and
reasonably so since they keep putting
chains on him
but he plays along with them nonetheless
so we might ask did fenrir have evil
intent before evil was done to him
the question might not have meant
anything to the norse
living in a culture with such rigid
ideas of fate fenrir was going to kill
odin no matter how he was treated in his
early days in osgard
perhaps chaining him up so brutally
makes his wrath that much worse
but surely odin's inevitable death day
would have come in the same way at the
same time as our own death day well for
each of us
but still perhaps that death would have
been an accident or a result of a less
atrocious war between the asean gods and
the other powers
perhaps in reacting to a prophecy rather
than merely accepting it the assaila
gods only sharpened the wolf's rage and
his teeth
and yet
long before loki had fathered this
monster brood with the anti-goddess
angrboda he was already a presence in
the asean god's lives
snori tells a story from these early
days in his prose edda which shows loki
in a less negative light
early on in the history of the cosmos
the asir had established their home in
asgard but had not yet fortified it
a builder came to the gods and offered
to make a wall around their realm so
high and so strong that none of their
enemies not even the strongest among the
anti-gods could get through
the builder promised that the work would
be completed within three seasons
and as his modest price he demanded only
the sun the moon and the goddess freyja
now the early north spoke in terms of
two seasons rather than four
with the year broken up into a summer
from april to october and a winter from
october to april
the gods thought that the year and a
half that the builder wanted was a lot
of time to ask for the work the builder
was promising especially given the steep
price he said
the god stipulated though that the
builder would have his prizes if he
completed the work within a much shorter
time only one winter that is half year
with all construction completed before
the first day of summer what we would
call mid-april
if any part of the work remained to be
done on that day the builder would
receive no reward from the gods at all
the assad gods also stipulated that the
builder could be helped by no man the
builder however asked that he'd be
allowed the help of his stallion
with the insistent encouragement of loki
the other gods accepted this compromise
so on the first day of the winter half
of the year an hour mid-october the
builder's work was begun
construction proceeded during the day
while at night the builder hauled stones
with the help of a stallion
everyone marveled at what a huge load of
stones the horse could haul
and because the stallion could move so
much more material than anyone expected
the work proceeded quickly
three days before the start of summer
the builder was close to holding up his
end of the bargain
this is when the assembled gods grew
worried
the prospect of giving up the sun the
moon and the goddess freyja was not
appealing
and after complaining bitterly in porn's
fingers they agreed this was really
loki's fault
since he was the one who recommended
that the builder enjoy the use of his
supernaturally strong horse
so the gods threatened loki with a
painful death if he didn't do something
now to prevent the builder from
finishing his work on time
that very evening when the builder was
picking up rocks at the stallion a mare
left out of the woods nearby
she naid i guess seductively
we are told by snorri that when the
stallion realized what kind of horse
this was
he went mad and broke his reins and ran
after the mayor
the mayor pranced away and kept the
stallion in pursuit all night but it
eventually went
as it goes with stallions and mares
and in the morning with his horse still
a-wall
the builder realized that he couldn't
possibly complete his wall in time
the builder went into what is described
as a rage apparently of a specific type
that somehow identified him as one of
the anti-gods
note that the asean gods otherwise had
shown no inclination to believe that he
was one of their enemies prior to this
suggesting again that there aren't any
visual cues that distinguish between god
and anti-god
but this rage called in the old norse
text of the story in snorri's prose edda
rage of anti-gods yottenburger
must somehow be a distinctive
characteristic of this family of beings
thor is sometimes said to go into what
might be the equivalent for his own
family and assire age or smother
the word moth here for rage is from the
same root as english mood
though specialized in old norse to refer
to a particular kind of raging mood
now that the builder had revealed his
true identity
and the wall was still not quite
complete at the end of the allotted time
the asean gods called on thor who showed
up to throw his hammer at the builder
and kill him
but we learn now that it was loki who
had taken the form of the mayor and
distracted the stallion
and in the course of time we might
presume about 11 months
loki the mayor gives birth to an
eight-legged stallion who will become
odinn's signature mount the great horse
sleipnir
of course
we see how wildly different in tone
different stories about loki can be
in one loki has fearsome children who
will murder the gods and yet and another
loki is the punchline in a weird and
kind of funny story that ends up with
one of his children a horse being very
useful to the gods
but strikingly loki is consistently
referred to as one of the gods never is
one of the anti-gods even though loki
leads the anti-gods at the final awful
combat of ragnarok
and also even though loki's ability to
shape change into animals makes him
resemble the anti-gods more than the
gods
as we hear in the edds of anti-gods in
the form of eagles for example
the gods themselves other than the two
most morally dubious odin and loki
aren't said to take animal forms
so this uncertain identity this duality
between loki as the author of evil and
the goofy sidekick
is present everywhere we come across
loki's name
the contradiction was so ingrained in
his character that we find echoes of it
even from very late
for example a story contained in a
collection of traditional folk rhymes
from the pharaoh islands only published
in 1822
still preserves some of the character of
loki in an unmistakable form
in this early 19th century story from a
remote corner of the scandinavian world
a farmer has lost a board game that he
played against an unnamed anti-god
and apparently
the unwise farmer and his anti-god
opponent
had wagered the farmer's son on the
outcome of the game
the farmer decides that his son must be
hidden from this anti-god and he prays
first to odinn
ooh then tries to hide the child by
causing a field of tall wheat stalks to
appear overnight and then turning the
boy into a grain of wheat on one of the
wheat stalks
but odinn has to bring the kid back to
his parents when the anti-god begins to
tear up the wheat
then the parents pray to the obscure
hanir who appears instantly
he turns the child into a feather on a
swan's head
but the anti-god kills the swan and
hener has to summon the child back to
him before he goes down the anti-god's
throat
now that both odin and hunir have failed
to hide the child effectively the farmer
and his wife call on loki
when loki appears he demands the farmer
build him a boathouse with a large
window that has an iron pole stuck on
the ground just inside it
the reason for this strange requirement
becomes clear only later
from that boathouse lucky launches a
fishing boat with the child in it
loki catches three halibut fish
loki then turns the child into a single
tiny egg of halibut row and throws the
fish back overboard
as loki rose back to shore the anti-god
notices him the two go back out to sea
together fishing and before long the
anti-god has caught the same three
halibut fish lookie did and is counting
out the row from one fish looking for
the boy
loki turns the boy back into his normal
form and casts him back on land where he
starts to run away
the anti-god leaps onto shore as well
and tries to follow but can only plod
along in the deep sand drifts
the nimbler boy reaches the boathouse
that his father built at loki's request
and jumps in
the bulkier anti-god tries to jump
through as well but gets caught in the
tight space inside and impales his head
on the iron pole set up within
loki comes up behind him and cuts off a
leg
but the leg grows back into the
anti-god's body
loki then cuts off the other leg
and stuffs stones and sticks between the
leg and the rest of the body to prevent
it from growing back
now the anti-god dies of his injuries
and the boy is reunited joyously with
his parents
this story while not preserved from as
early as the miss and the eddas
contains elements that point to an
archaic origin
in particular
the trio of odin
and loki must have had some kind of
significance at one time
we will see the same trio journey
together when loki introduces the cursed
ring into the story of the volsungs
and we see the same trio when an
anti-god in eagle form named thiazi
demands the goddess even and her apples
we'll get
to both of these myths in other lectures
this trio is probably also responsible
for creating human beings from driftwood
according to the version of the poetic
era
though they are named there in the
pombola spa as odinn
and the otherwise obscure name lother
because this trio is otherwise identical
and because odinn is called in multiple
poetic sources alternately loki's friend
and luther's friend
it does seem reasonable to assume that
lothar is simply one of loki's names
like so many of the gods including odinn
and thor he has many
but who is
why is he seen almost only in a trio
with odinn and loki
this question might have become
unanswerable
henr has no speaking part in any myth
and aside from his role in the creation
of human beings he seems to play no
active part at all
but when he appears in our most reliable
sources the poetic and prose zetta this
obscure god hanir appears only in
association with loki so can it be that
herniated is in fact closely related to
loki
names are so various in norse myth that
it is possible henir is simply another
name for a figure we know otherwise
under a different name
whether a familiar figure or an obscure
one whether a god or anti-god
the meaning of the name hunir is
difficult to link to any other clues
it looks for all the world like it might
be formed the root hen which is the same
root as hen i.e chicken in english
but it seems odd that the norse would
hold up a cosmic scale version of
colonel sanders next odin and loki in
what seems to be a submerged but genuine
memory of a powerful deific trio in
odinn loki and hunnier
hens were never particularly important
to the norse culturally speaking and are
never even discussed much as sources of
food
but while hens are not important in
norse mythology
roosters are
and hunir could be read as
henner this might suggest either that
hunir is somehow related to the cosmic
roosters
who crow to warn of the coming of
ragnarok
or if we take hinner as a hunter of hind
perhaps he's connected to the figure of
the hawk which is associated with both
odin and loki too
odinn after all appears as a hawk after
he exchanges riddles with king heidrek
in the saga
and loki appears as a hawk when he
borrows the feather suit from craig or
froya
i have wondered just how deep the
connection between hanir and loki might
go
it is conceivable that hunir is one of
loki's even more obscure brothers
although without knowing anything about
honey's origin or much about loki's that
can never go beyond speculation
this is just another place where the
limited number of surviving sources
makes us reach a wall in the hedge maze
of norse myth and wonder what could be
over the wall
the meaning of loki's own name is not
immediately obvious but probably shares
the same root as the english word lock
a similar formation proti from the word
for break means broken trees so possibly
loki is the locked one
a reference either to his lips being
locked shut but being sewn together or
perhaps to his punishment of being
locked below the earth
another possibility since the same root
for lock is used for ending a period of
time is that loki is the ender perhaps
with reference to his role in the
ragnarok story
in that case his name will be formed
from the loch root in the same way that
scotty shooter archer is formed from the
shoot root
but like most of the gods loki is known
by many alternate names and poetries
the most prominent is
suggesting sky
in loki's name lolter has perplexed
scholars for a long time as well because
he's not a god particularly associated
with this guy
true he flies through it on some
occasions but with wings borrowed from a
goddess
but there may be another explanation of
this name that accords better with the
known facts about him
if loki's name loster is foreign from
the root lo which means praise
its english relative with slightly
different meaning as love
then it could conceivably be an archaic
form of the past participle praised the
praised one
it's interesting to note one context in
which this name is used for him by
someone else the goddess give you in the
poem lokasena
i think lothter loki is a cheerful
fellow
everyone loves him
in many other mythic traditions fearsome
gods or god approximate beings like loki
are given euphemistic or conciliatory
names
the name shiva means the civil one
hardly a fitting title for that hindu
bringer of death
in greece aeschylus's orostea features
the renaming of the furies
to the gracious-minded eumenides
likewise although loki is a god who
brings trouble even when he's not
actively malevolent
it's possible he might be addressed with
a name that softens him up in a
comparable way
that was certainly the context when
gevin calls him lotter when she is
trying to get loki to stop his mockeries
in the poem lokasena
yet while we have seen in this lecture
that loki is counted among the gods he
is never really ready to stop causing
them harm
next time
we'll turn to the death of balder where
loki enters the gods and prefigures the
bloody
final conflict at ragnarok
[Music]
you